[Applause]  a chance to send the thunder home  lillard long range three and it's good  are you kidding me  [Applause]  oh my goodness look at that  shot to put them out he went for  50 points that's point that was 47  48 9 and 50 points on that one that's  amazing  five years ago lillard  hit a three against your rockets  to win a first round series  damien lillard for 50 points  [Music]  good night oklahoma city  sees it over wow  finney smith the inbounds back to doncic  [Applause]  dutchess pulls up three-pointer bang  bang it's good doncic wins the game  at the buzzer let's go  [Applause]  finney smith to inbound back to doncic  [Applause]  dodges pulls up three-pointer bang  bang it's good doncic wins the game at  the buzzer  let's go  luca dutchess  luca for one two  [Applause]  three  a good three